now this is very exciting in case you
haven't heard Hunger Games starlet
Jennifer Lawrence made a big
announcement yesterday I'm going to take
the next year off I'm gonna be working
with this organization what part of
represent us um it's just trying to get
you know young young people engaged
politically you know on a local level I
doesn't have anything to do with
partisans so it's just anti-corruption
stuff trying to pass state by state laws
that can help prevent corruption fix our
democracy
that's all Wow well we also learned
today that actor George Clooney is
donating five hundred thousand bucks for
the March for our lives that's promoted
as a totally student-organized
gun-control rally and the Ocean's eleven
actor the tequila Baron that's he's been
sniffing around politics for 20-plus
years let's not forget 2016 he raised 15
million dollars in one weekend that's
pretty good for Hillary Clinton and
other Democrats and of course he was
horrified by that it is an obscene
amount of money the Sanders campaign
when they talk about it is absolutely
right it's ridiculous that we should
have this kind of money in politics I
agree completely
of course you gotta love Clooney because
he went out to say if asked
he'd engage in this obscene act again
and keep raising money I mean it's legal
so it's gonna keep doing it in 2016
Tinseltown thought that they could
continue their Hollywood on the Potomac
routine by putting all their chips on
Hillary after all they had helped her
husband who had been a fairly successful
two-term president
- that impeachment thing and they stayed
in the Lincoln Bedroom they flocked to
the White House Correspondents Dinner
was all hunky-dory but Hollywood was cut
out of the picture under george w and
hollywood mocked him endlessly and
viciously so when the most left-wing
president ever was elected Barack Obama
it was Nirvana for all those
entertainers who had felt disrespected
and offended by the veil
existence of Bush and certainly of
conservatives but with the Obamas oh
they celebrated from the beginning the
inauguration birthdays White House
parties even in the Situation Room that
is a cool photo all the way to the end
for eight years you kept your word and
you're calm you are the epitome of cool
they were having fun come on
does that look fun I was sad to see
President Obama go because he echoed
their worldview and Samuel Jackson said
he had that Hollywood cool factor let's
face it Trump even though he had a hit
show with The Apprentice he was never
really part of their world because on
some key issues he thought differently
and he dared to speak up when so many in
the entertainment arena put all their
money their chips on Hillary
they raised so much money like Clooney
and on a winter let's face it when Trump
was elected they were embarrassed and
furious most in the entertainment and
sports in crowd they see Trump
supporters as either ignorant racist or
bible-thumping fanatics George Clooney
to his credit put blame where it
belonged on Hillary
he told The Daily Beast after she lost
it was frustrating because I never saw
her elevate her game I never saw it and
I had a lot of liberal friends who were
like she's not good at this well I agree
George and let's face it
top tier celebs surrounded by PR people
managers agents and millions of adoring
fans yeah they can get pretty used to
coasting on political cliches they're
used to dishing it out against
conservatives sometimes in the vilest of
terms without ever having to explain
themselves and without ever getting
called on it so when celebs wade into
politics as we're seeing today with
Jennifer Lawrence and George Clooney
well they win fans on their political
side but then they can alienate many
more you think of what happened for
instance when the NFL I don't kind of
star oh they're all stars Colin
Kaepernick refused to stand for the
anthem what happened was he spurred
other players to do the same well then
the NFL lost tens of millions of dollars
in advertising revenue during the
regular season as viewership took a
sizable hit and attendance was down
people were furious so if two heavily
infected by politics the sports stage
and screen they kind of just become like
everything else in Washington nasty and
polarizing call me crazy but I think we
need more not fewer places where we can
gather cheer and even boo without
worrying about politics everyone has a
right to speak their mind but stars on
screen and those on the field should
know that when they traffic in hateful
political vitriol they're likely to get
some serious pushback just like the rest
of us in politics or political analysis
well now it's your turn Clooney and
Jennifer Lawrence why don't you explain
beyond just epithets or bromides cliches
or sometimes maybe insults your own
ideas on how to grow the economy how to
increase the standard of living for the
poor and middle-class Americans how to
decrease violence and drug addiction
you see if you really want to get into
the political ring really you can't just
talk to your fans or even write a check
you need to be daring enough to go into
unfamiliar and even hostile territory
and answer tough questions think about
Oprah maybe for a millisecond she mulled
dipping her toe into the political pond
and she quickly pulled it out there were
rumors of Kid Rock running for the
Senate rumors that the rock may hit the
trail
well now Clooney who's worth hundreds of
millions of dollars good on him for
earning that cash he's shoveling money
at gun control it's his right to do that
but as Democrats watch worry and hope
that you know someone's there next Obama
maybe even Clooney because he's a star
with a killer smile and that cool factor
got to think about what the
repercussions will be our celebrities
really the best candidates at least
celebrities that are not quite Ronald
Reagan because remember he was an actor
and people say Laura you work for Reagan
so don't you have a double standard here
no no no it's true I did work for
President Reagan I'm a Reagan
conservative but remember what Reagan
did he spent at least two decades
studying reading debating anyone who
would debate him and writing on politics
he was masterful he was a successful
two-term Governor of California he ran
for president in 1976 he lost the
nomination by a hair and then had to
come clawing his way back four years
later to change politics forever it did
not happen overnight he didn't just
write a check or launch into insults
against his opponents he did more than
just drive by hits on his political
adversaries or just raise gobs of money
for his political friends I think what
most of these celebrities will find out
is that the talents that make them mega
stars and acting sports or music don't
always translate into politics at least
not with a without a lot of really hard
work and you can't just issue ad hominem
attack
on your political opponents without
making a substantive argument at some
point politics is not easy on the red
carpet there's also a big downside for
people in need of adoration in today's
environment that moment you enter
politics national politics let's face it
you alienate half the country millions
of people will instantly dislike you
many will hate you
others will lie about you still others
just to elevate themselves and win back
power will say vile and hateful things
that are demonstrably false let's face
this most celebrities have no desire to
risk their cushy lives to really mix it
up big time in politics thinking about
it the only one I can remember
post-reagan who did this is the one
celeb also a businessman like Clooney
that they are now vilifying 24/7 and
that's the angle